a new series gives viewers an
unprecedented look inside America's
prisons it's called appropriately enough
inside story and it was created by
former prisoners and it's aimed mostly
at people who are still serving time it
covers issues like minimum wage which
most prisoners do not get and the effect
of minors being incarcerated with adults
series includes an interview with two
men with first-hand experience of the
prison system take a look
so no matter how you look at it you're
going to be like kind of developing
developing into what's around you like
they took the years away
That was supposed to teach us how to
grow up and be a man and replaced it
with straight yeah violence
yeah the video series is a joint
production between The Marshall Project
and Vice news and Lawrence Bartley who
is a co-creator and the host joins us
now Lawrence thank you for being here
thank you for having me this is a
tremendous accomplishment what was the
idea behind it well you know during the
pandemic we we thought that we wanted to
pull the curtain back on a criminal
justice system people were it was it was
in certainty on what the pandemic was
doing was hard to get news on the inside
and they're about three out of five
incarcerated people have some literacy
issues and that poses a problem because
we have a print publication called news
insiders which we try to disseminate
information but they can't read it they
can't get the info so we decided to
create a TV series that would do just
that it's a great idea I mean we are a
visual culture right so this solves that
problem uh you were incarcerated as a 17
year old which speaks to this big issue
that nobody seems to think is a good
idea except for the prison and justice
system itself of putting minors people
who are still children still developing
in with adults talk about the dangers of
that and you spent over 20 years in
prison we should say yeah those guys
saying you know we what do we learn here
we come out
tougher than when we went in it's not
Rehabilitation and there isn't no
because you know I spent 27 years in in
prison and at a time where I was
learning how to shave I was just a kid
and I was in there in a Maximum Security
Prison with an adult so that's what my
brain is developing at that period and
to to inject violence to inject despair
to inject sadness and separation in
there it it can it can kind of take a
person for a loop and 95 percent of the
people who are in prisons in jails come
out one day to society yeah that's why
we should care that's why we all should
care yeah yeah and next to you at
Walmart Lowe's and we should all care
because it affects us all and we talk
about
um getting out and becoming a better
version of yourself or becoming I would
say a more exaggerated version of the
person you were when you went in and
that's the separation between the two
this program is available in 1200 jails
and prisons why is it important for the
currently incarcerated to watch
because it's hard to get information on
the inside it's screened very heavily
and the screening process is subjective
and also a lot of prisons and jails are
located in rural areas and and in order
to get television programs or like news
show that's really robust news shows you
have to rely on the prison
administrator's kindness to pay for
cable all incarcerated people have to
come up with a a way to sell products as
approved by the administration that they
could pay for it but even so they don't
get news that's relevant to their lives
and this is so relevant to their lives
yeah and not to toot my own horn but I'm
someone who been there where they are
yeah they see the reflection of me and I
know that I'm giving them something
that's truly real yeah by the way you
got your master's degree while you were
in prison absolutely congratulations to
you on that thank you thank you but I
think it's important to make this point
because I was one of those people if you
do the crime then you should do the time
and it's not until so for me you start
educating yourself about the injustices
that you see and how it affects black
and brown people in particular but what
do you say to people that said look you
did the crime you should be in prison
well you know prisons are there for a
purpose not to say that everyone should
get out you know you're not advocating
bad people walking around the streets
not at all but what we're trying to do
is to show the world that people in
prison are human beings too they have
hopes and dreams just like everyone else
and once they're serving their time it's
better to instill rehabilitation in them
let them let them know that education is
important let them see their families
let them have phone calls let them do
all the things that make them feel human
so they come out as kind individuals not
come out with angst and because angst
leads to crime and no one wants that
yeah you have a woman in there Tyra
Patterson who said Humanity cannot wait
for freedom and that's why it's so
important to tell these stories well I
was going to ask how you got the the
access I mean this is not PR for the
prison system so you know how'd you get
the cooperation right it's very tough is
it working behind the scenes police
officers in this yes I talked to police
detectives in there you know I all along
some experiences that some of the
conversations I had with superintendents
or wildly knowing the wardens but during
my time in prison I guess they
encapsulated all I met this security
captain and those security captains the
job is to be hard and Stern and to say
no of all things but this security
Captain told me one day that I have to
go home and look at myself in the mirror
at night and if I don't like what I see
looking back at me then I'm doing
something wrong yeah so by making a
series like this it allows prison
administrators to look at it and look at
some of the injustices you see and weigh
it against what they're doing in their
prisons and I'm hoping that that
Humanity will leak through in them and
they'll allow holding up well said yeah
everyone could look at them Humanity ask
themselves Lawrence Bartley thank you
very much thank you congratulations new
episodes of Inside Story air every
Thursday on Vice news or at the
marshallproject.org we'll be right back